deux hectares de dalles démoli pour
changer le visage du quartier du loup
voix à vélizy un chantier inédit en
france qui rentre en ce début d'année
2010 neuf dans sa phase finale et qui
devrait s'achever fin 2020 c'est ce
qu'on appelle une opération tiroir
en gros on a construit un port un
programme immobilier avec du commerce au
rez de chaussée qui nous a permis de
relocaliser les activités du centre
commercial qu'on va démolir
en parallèle on a construit du parking
public voilà l'objectif c'est que on
conserve en permanence toutes les
capacités de stationnement du quartier
et qui est une continuité de service une
comptine une continuité dans l'activité
du centre commercial mais aussi d'autres
puisque on a des entreprises qui sont
sur cydia du service et un cabinet
médical
conçu dans les années soixante dix et
cinq tours de près de 2000 logements ne
répondait plus aux nouvelles exigences
des habitants elle sa refonte permet
d'optimiser l'arrivée en 2016 du tramway
t6 on avait vingt mille mètres carrés
dalle juste derrière et on supprime les
vingt mille mètres carrés dalle pour
retrouver le seul naturel et c'est là
que c'est innovant puisque à cette
dimension là j'en avais pas conscience
quand on a lancé le projet mais en fait
c'est la première fois que on supprime
vingt mille mètres carrés pour faire
entrer la forêt dans la ville dont
concret une rue qui va du tramway à la
forêt on a transport transférer les tous
les commerces qui se retrouvent avec des
vraies boutiques
dans la rue et ont créé en fait une vie
de quartier qu'on n'avait pas et là on
se retrouve avec les riverains qui
reprennent le plaisir et qui ronflent
vite pris possession de ce nouveau
quartier avec cette dalle qui va être
totalement transformé mené par sita
llose le budget global de l'aménagement
dépasse les 80 millions d'euros autre
chiffre à la création de 150 logements
d'un cabinet médical de 950 m² ou encore
d'un équipement sportif de 4500 m²
[Musique]